welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your one and only host
eric trexler but today i am joined by a
very special temporary guest co-host his
name is greg knuckles greg how are you
doing
doing well thanks for having me on this
is our first episode since our little
winter break did you enjoy your break i
did did you
absolutely i did my annual
pilgrimage up to the mountains of west
virginia sweet very underrated state in
my opinion
uh yeah it was awesome man i hadn't been
in
zero degree weather in a while and it's
very refreshing for a week
and then you
go to warmer places good deal
all right so a couple announcements here
to start the show uh we are back from
break and we'll be doing a bunch of
episodes in the next few months for sure
um if you like the show as always be
sure to like it rate it and subscribe on
whatever platform you use
if you want to help out supporting the
show
you can do that by using the discount
code sbs pod sbs pod at
bulksupplements.com that'll get you a 5
discount off of your order
you could also subscribe to the mass
research review that greg and i are both
co-authors of along with dr mike zordos
dr eric helms and then of course you
could also try our diet app called macro
factor which does have a free trial so
you can take it for a spin and see if
you like it
now that we're back from break there are
some changes to the podcast format that
we wanted to make everyone aware of
the show will have the same general
format but
the episodes are going to be a little
shorter so they're probably going to be
closer to an hour rather than like the
typical
six hours that we've been pushing lately
and as you're listening to this just
look down at the bottom of your little
podcasting app and see how close we came
to the hour mark on this episode uh if
if passed is prelude this one will
probably still be two hours or so no no
no no we'll see 90 minutes it'll be 90
minutes we'll see but yeah we're
thinking an hour hour and a half per
episode was about half of what we
normally do but
lest you feel like you're being deprived
of show the big change is that we're
going to be doing shows that are half
the length but twice the frequency so
instead of putting up an episode every
other thursday we're going to put one up
every single thursday
outside of whenever we happen to take
breaks
so
same general selection of segments but
fewer segments per episode
is basically
the whole change so with that in mind
how is the road to the stage going
road to the stage is going well uh
officially back at it so i
uh took took a little bit over a month
off over the holidays just you know
didn't want to
be stressed about trying to lose weight
during thanksgiving time christmas time
a lot of good food uh so yeah
took it easy for about a month month and
a half and i'm back to it i hit a new
low this week at 233
and my trend weight in macro factor is
currently at its lowest ever so 234.8
as of this morning
so yeah things are uh things are back on
track
all right good stuff how is the road to
athens uh so far so good um
people might recall i started out with a
great deal of enthusiasm i was doing a
lot of really long runs but with
relatively low frequency
ended up having a little issue with my
pop lydias which is fun fact the most
useless muscle in your lower body and if
i seem salty i am
but um i've been having a lot of success
lately with doing shorter but more
frequent runs
and i've also had more success running
on flat surfaces so i've been doing a
lot of running on pavement i had been
doing really long trail runs and
uh from what i understand that is like
the best way to
bother your popliteus so that kind of
checks out
but yeah shorter runs
on more predictable flatter surfaces
and i'm feeling good you know my my
joints are a lot less beat up i'm not
running into those annoying little
muscle strains like the pop lydias and
uh i'm really excited about the fact
that uh you know it's now february which
means we're kind of past the hardest
winter months like if you're doing an
outdoor exercise activity like i don't
want to complain north carolina has very
mild winters like it's not like we're
putting up with that much
but it's a lot easier to run when it's
50 out rather than when it's like 25 and
that's degrees fahrenheit for people
um so yeah i think you know i'm kind of
getting to the point in the year where
you have fewer of those runs where it's
like frigid out
you have longer throughout the day like
you can get out there earlier in the
morning later in the evening so um it's
just gonna get easier and easier from
here until we hit like november so i'm
pretty stoked about that sounds good
all right what about feats of strength
what do we got yeah so i've got four uh
this time around we've got uh three
training lifts and a competition lift
so starting off with the deadlift
uh kristoff weir bicky and jamal browner
both recently hit
uh
absurd training lifts uh sumo with
straps
uh where bicky pulled
1068 pounds or 484 and a half kilos
and jamal browner pulled a
1065 pounds or 483 kilos
so
those are
absurd numbers obviously
uh you know obviously all standard
caveats apply you know we'll we'll see
if they can hold on to
numbers like that in a meat setting
um
but though i mean regardless of straps
in competition out of competition
whatever
those are the two biggest sumo deadlifts
that i'm aware of so
just strong people being strong and uh
as always very much hope they can hit it
on the platform can i share a
controversial opinion i don't know if
we've ever discussed this on the show go
for it my controversial opinion is that
absolutely straps should 100 be allowed
in powerlifting that is my opinion
why
because it's just more fun like it's to
me it's such a shame when someone's
deadlift is limited by their grip
strength like i know that there's a
million uh grip sport athletes who are
just
pounding their computer screen right now
with me saying that but i've always been
well here's my
here's what it is my grip limits my
deadlift and i hate it that frustrates
me yeah no that's fair i can definitely
see it either way um
so one of the things that i do find kind
of interesting
is that
there there are a lot of people who get
very upset when they see someone binge
with a really big arch uh
you know they say it's they say it's a
matter of fairness you know like this
person their range of motion is only two
inches and this person it's it's a foot
and a half how's that fair or whatever
um
you know you don't see anyone shedding
crocodile tears for people who just have
really tiny hands and can't hold on to
the bar for dead like you know no one
looks at someone with huge hands and
they're like that's an unfair advantage
like cut their fingers off right um
which and so like
my general perspective on it is like who
cares like ultimately
with us with pretty much any competitive
sport
what you're looking for is people with
just outlier traits that allow them to
do well
in whatever sport that is and then they
train hard and they're better than
everyone else and they uh they're very
successful
so you know i i see
people with small hands much like myself
who might have grip issues it's just
like ah you know what
you didn't win the genetic lottery on
this one sucks to be you um
but just from like a pure fairness
perspective like if someone were to try
to level the playing field i do think uh
in a general sense straps would make the
sport fairer um
yeah i i personally don't care i wish
that there was uh
i i wish that there was just like a
straps category you know like that that
is one of the things i find a little bit
interesting
because like you know there's uh
there's divisions where you can wear a
bench shirt squat suit
even among raw you can go like with knee
wraps without knee wraps like really the
only common piece of lifting equipment
like used as a training aid that's not
allowed in competition in any way shape
or form is straps yeah so i i don't know
that i would like straps for just
the normal competition but i i think it
would be cool if there was like a straps
only deadlift division i'll settle for
that that's fine with me
um
all right so uh moving on to the bench
daniel zamani
hit a training lift of 350 kilos or
771 pounds uh i believe the the meat
that is planned kind of the head-to-head
clash with daniel zamani and julius
maddox is coming up
i don't i don't remember exactly when
but i think it's i think it's within the
next month or so
so uh
you know we'll we'll see if one of those
two gentlemen is the first to break 800
pounds at that meet i and i i think
that's what they're both aiming for
that'll be cool and then finally in the
world of equipped lifting i think this
one's very cool um
so
we don't talk about every
uh like multiply unlimited equipment uh
all-time world record
one just because you know that there's
not that many multiplied lifters in our
audience less general interest and two
just the the sport has low key falling
off like the heyday of multiply lifting
was was about a decade ago but there has
been a lot of movement uh specifically
in the bench press world record within
the past couple of years um
it's been it's been changing hands uh
pretty frequently like i think with a
greater frequency
than it has since like the mid 2000s
when uh mendelssohn and jean richlock
and uh ryan canelli were kind of trading
the record back and forth anyway the the
person who recently
uh arrested it from the crowd and now
sits atop the mountain is none other
than bill gillespie
which that might not be a name that
rings a bell for
most people listening to this but if
you've been in powerlifting for a while
you know who bill gillespie is
he's he's one of kind of like the
ultimate old school guys in the sport
he's been competing
for
in excess of 40 years maybe maybe close
to 50 years at this point um but he's 62
years old and as far as i'm aware he's
never held the bench press all-time
world record and you know he's he's just
been grinding away
and uh you know finally summited the
mountaintop at 62 years old and then
retired you know going out like jordan
both the first and second time we don't
talk about the third time uh
but yeah in
you know there are plenty of
very successful power lifters in their
50s or 60s where you know every time
they do something big everyone's like oh
my god how are they so strong at that
age but
dude i can't imagine holding 1100 pounds
in my hands period and i'm a i'm a
healthy young buck uh
this guy's 62 years old and who cares
about the equipment like just a man that
age being able to hold 1100 pounds in
his hands absolutely insane so
uh congrats to him and it is
just awesome to see such a
long-lifting career be able to end on
such an accomplishment man i'm just
thinking of the bone density oh yes
forearms it's got to be insane oh man
that's crazy yeah
all right so moving on i've got a
research review segment on atp
supplementation are you familiar with
atp greg i've heard of it yeah so if you
open up
literally any book that will make any
mention of biology you will read early
in the book that atp
is the energy currency of the body right
or the energy currency of the cell
so
when we talk about energy in a
physiological context a lot of times we
talk about
you know especially in the nutrition
world we talk about carb and fat and
protein and calories and things like
that
and that's all good but ultimately in
order to do stuff in the body that
requires energy we got to break that
stuff down into atp and that basically
is
a huge uh
a huge portion of what we call
metabolism it's just figuring out how do
we get from these ingested calories down
to atp to do a bunch of stuff in the
body
now
atp does
a lot of things you know it's
like i said it's the currency it's it's
the thing that's being exchanged when
you're talking about processes that
require energy
but
atp is very critical for muscle
contractions and this is why it gets so
much attention uh in the fitness world
so when muscles are contracting there
are a lot of processes that obviously
require energy we need to be pumping
calcium all over the place we need to be
pumping
sodium and potassium
we need to be helping the myosin head
release itself from actin
and so atp is involved in all of these
energetic processes of muscle
contraction so the concept which sounds
very nice on paper is
it'd be really great if we could provide
some extra atp for our body
via direct oral supplementation you know
if exercise requires so much atp and
it's so important for muscle contraction
then when we're lifting weights it seems
like it'd be really nice to have some
extra atp around
so this is something that has been
studied um you know over the last 15 or
20 years or so
on a number of occasions and so what i
want to do in this segment is talk about
kind of the historical context of atp
supplements and you know atp boosting
supplements and and then kind of tie
that into a recent study that came out
just this year
so back in 2004
there was a study by jordan and
colleagues
and they were looking at atp
supplementation they dosed it at 150
milligrams and also they dosed it at 225
milligrams to see if one or the other or
both
might be more favorable than a placebo
they basically found no significant
benefits when they were comparing these
different uh these different groups so
they had nine subjects per group um
there were some little within group
changes so like oh from before to after
supplementation in this group we saw a
significant increase but at the end of
the day in a placebo-controlled
randomized controlled trial like this
what you're trying to identify is
relative to placebo did these different
doses of the supplement significantly
outperform that placebo treatment so in
this case um you know there were enough
of those little within group differences
to get people
interested
but at the end of the day a rigorous
kind of by-the-book interpretation of
the stats would indicate that there was
no significant benefit beyond that of a
placebo
and even within some of those little
within group changes you have to be
really careful just based on some of the
details of the methods i i think they
did a really nice job with the study so
i don't want to sound overly critical
but
um you know there were some very obvious
outliers they did a really nice job
reporting some of those individual level
changes so like in one case i'm pretty
sure single dose supplementation for one
person added like
over 28 kilograms to their chest press
and that was really just
i would i would speculate
has something to do with the fact that
the chest press increments were not very
small so it was like you could move up
one plate or two or three plates it was
like a machine based kind of deal
that of course wouldn't alone explain it
but also just sometimes you come in you
have a crappy day or sometimes you're
just really unfamiliar with chest
pressing and after a few sessions it
goes up by a tremendous amount right but
rest assured no one is taking an atp
supplement and saying you know what i
feel 30 kilograms stronger on my bench
right now yeah that's not gonna happen
so
this was a study you know it served its
purpose as kind of the first study that
i'm aware of in this area that kind of
set the stage for future studies to kind
of build upon
um but
herta and colleagues came in
2008 with a purported atp boosting
supplement and once again
supplementation did not lead to any
really exciting differences between
groups
one thing i forgot to mention
in the jordan study from 2004 probably
one of the most important things from
that study good thing i glossed over it
yeah i i was wondering if uh
if there was gonna be some sort of like
big twist reveal at the end no let's get
let's get all the cards on the table so
the supplement in the jordan study
whether it was given a 150 milligrams of
atp or 225 it did not increase blood atp
levels um and it was really great that
they checked in that study but obviously
that's something that really sets the
stage for major limitations in future
research where you're like
well if an atp supplement is not
increasing circulating atp levels at
least based on you know plasma or crm
measurements
what might be going on here if a
supplement did work right so jordan in
2004
no real significant benefits herda in
2008 no real significant benefits um and
then there was a study by lowry and
colleagues actually a series of studies
by lowry and colleagues all coming out
of jacob wilson's lab down at the
university of tampa
this was a series of studies where they
looked at different combinations of atp
and hmb supplementation sometimes both
of them together
and this series of studies i'm just kind
of going to
hit the highlights of it like i'm not
going to go in into really
deep depth about the various
methodological details because
this series of studies
received very considerable interest from
the scientific community um
you know it it received at least one
letter to the editor this group of
studies um that raised some questions
about the results and and things that
appeared to be inconsistencies from
study to study um one of the things that
really got a lot of attention and
various blog posts and articles covered
this
the reported effects from different
combinations of atp and hmb
were
very comparable in magnitude to just
straight up using steroids
because there are studies on
using steroids and lifting weights uh
controlled studies and so
um
there was a lot of back and forth about
that at face you know on the surface it
seemed quite implausible that atp and
hmb would have this kind of effect
because both had been studied previously
and had never done that type of thing
and then you dig deeper and it seems
even more implausible yeah
and you know i remember one of the
things that came up i saw a lot of
people say well no it's just there was
this really hard training program and
that's why it did this thing but like
the placebo group also did the training
program yeah and had very
you know fairly typical placebo group
type gains
and so
that would kind of necessarily imply
that like
the training details don't even really
matter unless you're throwing the good
stuff in there with the hmb and the atp
like
so yeah there was just a lot of stuff
that came up that seemed relatively
implausible
a lot of scientists um
you know kind of
echoed that that um skepticism about
these studies there were letters to the
editor
and so that's kind of
uh where i leave it with that particular
series of studies but uh there's been
another kind of wave of atp
studies coming out so
uh de freitas and colleagues in 2019
uh they had subjects taking oral atp
supplements at a dose of 400 milligrams
and they ended up completing
significantly greater volume load
across four sets of half squats and this
was you know in comparison to a placebo
treatment so in that study it looked
like okay for some reason
and again the mechanisms really aren't
very clear
it appeared that atp given at 400
milligrams was helping people complete
greater volume load in their training so
maybe this would be a nice training aid
that helps you complete more volume per
session per training block and and
potentially would uh facilitate better
longitudinal adaptations to training and
that is a leap going from acute effects
on training volume to longitudinal
effects on training adaptations but that
would be the thought process there so
helms actually reviewed that study in
mass and he did a really nice job
summarizing all of this atp literature
up to that point
and helms you know came into it with an
open mind and basically concluded based
on the evidence you know
maybe atp supplementation
could possibly enhance performance but
if it did
it appeared at that point specifically
that it would help in circumstances
where you're doing you know multiple
sets taken to failure or multiple sets
with short rest periods it's about kind
of attenuating some of that fatigue in
higher volume sessions where fatigue is
really ramping up between sets
uh however that that was his kind of um
you know that was his like
maybe there could be something in these
scenarios but he also
uh concluded that based on the
inconsistent findings in the literature
uh and the uncertainty related to the
actual mechanism by which atp
supplementation would work uh he advised
readers to hold off on atp
supplementation until more conclusive
research became available so
he's like maybe it could kind of work in
some of these scenarios but we don't
know why and the research seems to be
really inconsistent so probably not a
safe bet with atp supplements uh now
there was a new study by dos santos
nunez de mora and colleagues in 2021 i
actually reviewed it as a research brief
uh in the mass research review that went
up today february 1st
so this study had 20 recreationally
trained male participants it was a
crossover design so each participant
completed all four of the study
conditions and the conditions were
either a placebo 100 milligrams of atp
200 milligrams of atp or 400 milligrams
of atp
and in all cases they were ingested 30
minutes prior to exercise testing so
they were doing four sets of barbell
half squats
squatting to about 90 degree knee angle
and they were using a load of 80 percent
of one rep max to
two minutes of rest between sets
so in terms of the findings uh the 400
milligram atp dose appeared to
significantly increase the number of
reps completed in set one
okay
but um this was not there were no
significant effects with the lower doses
uh and also none of the atp doses led to
significantly greater uh total reps or
total volume when you look across all
four sets
so what's really important about that
is that you know dr helms the good
doctor eric helms tentatively said okay
maybe atp could do something but based
on the literature it should have its
biggest impact potentially
if you're doing multiple set performance
theoretically to failure it should be in
the later sets when it's
attenuating this fatigue that we really
see atp shining as a supplement in this
case it only appeared to matter in the
first set which kind of goes against
that um that rationale
and also i think
you would have to question the utility
of a supplement you know if you were to
take a supplement and you're doing a you
know 16 set workout and it's like this
will help you do more reps
on set number one
but but not 2 through 16 and not total
you know it's not going to favorably
impact your total training volume in the
session
i would very
strongly question the utility of that
type of supplement if that's
representative of the true effects right
um
and so
yet again we find ourselves in a
situation with atp supplementation where
when we look at the applied research and
we say okay what is a dose that should
work and in what circumstances should it
do some predictable thing related to
physiology
we still have a lot of ambiguity and a
lot of inconsistency so
every time a study like this comes out
some people who are more
uh supplement friendly are very quick to
pick it up and say hey looks like atp
actually works now let's go ahead and
supplement with it i'm still quite
skeptical
for two main reasons first of course is
the inconsistency related to the applied
findings but the second one that we
really can't overlook
is that i really struggle to identify a
mechanism that seems
both plausible
and optimally targeted by atp
supplementation so
the two most common mechanisms you'll
see there
the first one is just very generally
increasing atp availability during
exercise like hey exercise requires atp
here's some more atp
the second mechanism you hear about a
lot is potentially
atp supplements increasing blood flow
via vasodilation so the idea
is that red blood cells kind of take up
this atp and that's why we're not seeing
it increase in like plasma after oral
supplementation and then during exercise
those
red blood cells are are kind of letting
go of that atp and helping promote
vasodilation during exercise
so the first
issue is with the atp availability one
so like
i was reading through a textbook and
this is really these numbers are really
baffling but
based on the textbook i was reading i
didn't bother to go in and recalculate
stuff so
uh
the human body based on the textbook
uses 40 kilograms of atp per day at rest
that's crazy i did i did not realize it
was that much yeah so again i didn't
bother to go through and recalculate but
somebody let this into a textbook
and i don't know seems fine for me but
40 kilograms of atp per day at rest and
during intense exercise
the textbook indicated that atp
utilization can reach up to 0.5
kilograms per minute when you're doing
like really intense continuous exercise
so
if we take those numbers at face value
and assume that they're even within the
ballpark of being close to true the idea
that you're going to introduce 400 more
milligrams so like
0.4 grams of atp
into exercise and actually do anything
with it you know anything beyond just a
drop in a bucket
it's just really implausible to think
yeah just to make the uh
just to make the math easier if we say
it's 500 milligrams yeah that would be
enough to cover
1 1000th of your atp needs per minute
during intense exercise
right and so which doesn't seem like
much yeah and and so if you're hearing
that you're saying well okay but that's
for 400 or 500 milligrams let's really
ramp it up the the human dose lift the
most baby exactly yeah so the human body
can only store about 80 to 100 grams of
atp at a time that's one of the reasons
that it's so important for us to be
continuously generating it is because we
can't just
have like a 40 kilogram
flap where we keep all of our atp that
we're gonna need for the day so um yeah
so like we need to constantly be
creating it throwing 400 milligrams into
the sea of atp
it's a drop in the bucket it's really
not going to matter so then the other
the other issue is through the whole
idea that the red blood cells are taking
it up and and eventually they're helping
to promote blood flow via vasodilation
and things like that
um
so
during exercise red blood cells do
release a little bit of atp this is part
of what promotes localized vasodilation
there's
really a lot of stuff going on during
exercise that manages vasodilation and
vasoconstriction during exercise
especially locally there are many many
things happening to make sure that the
muscle is getting sufficient blood flow
to do the exercise it needs to do
also a lot of control going on to make
sure that
blood is circulating appropriately so
that we don't have insane fluctuations
in blood pressure and and you know uh
cardiac output and things like that so
this is a finely tuned response
um now
there are conditions where you might see
that uh atp released from red blood
cells is reduced and so this could
potentially attenuate vasodilation
during conditions of exercise or
conditions of hypoxia so it is possible
that
attenuating atp released from red blood
cells could be problematic in maximally
facilitating this vasodilation however
this is generally seen in older
sedentary people in experimental
conditions so we don't usually see this
kind of impaired atp release from red
blood cells in young healthy people we
also see that this impairment that kind
of occurs with age is attenuated very
considerably in older athletes so the
idea that we're seeing these huge
effects of atp supplementation in young
healthy active people
i think it's relatively implausible
based on this particular mechanism and
everything that comes with it
so
i'm just not there yet with atp
supplements i don't think the applied
research is consistent enough for me
personally
i don't think the mechanisms are very
clearly elucidated we know that plasma
kind of circulating atp is not
increasing to
a noticeable degree
when it's provided as a supplement
uh perhaps red blood cells are taking it
up for for later use but i'm just not
seeing a clear mechanism that would
explain uh some of the applied findings
that have been observed doesn't mean
that atp could not possibly do anything
it's just the research really isn't
there yet to give you a really strong
basis for what it's doing and how it's
doing it so
one of my things that i want to focus on
moving forward is not just shooting down
ideas but also trying to
make sure i'm giving good alternatives
and being maximally helpful
so
let's say that you found some of those
mechanisms to be interesting
atp availability and vasodilation
one of the reasons that i really see atp
supplementation as a non-starter is
because we already have really good
supplements for both of those things so
if you're really interested in
maximizing atp availability during
exercise i can think of no greater
supplement than creatine monohydrate oh
i thought you were going to say epo
well
supplement
supplement
so uh creatine monohydrate like you know
we talked about the
amount of atp that you need relative to
the dose provided it just doesn't make
any sense physiologically it's a drop in
the bucket when we supplement with
creatine monohydrate we can increase our
total creatine concentration in muscle
by you know up to 15 to 30 percent if
we're a responder to creatine and we can
increase phospho-creatine resynthesis by
up to 20 to 50 percent these are real
big physiologically relevant changes in
the phosphagen energy system that
provides atp during intense exercise so
if you're really intrigued in thinking
oh i'd like to use a supplement that
increases atp availability during
exercise
go with creatine it's tried and true
there's a million studies on it
if you want more vasodilation this is
something we've talked about a million
times before
uh
four to six grams of citrulline and or
400 to 800 milligrams of dietary nitrate
it's an extremely straightforward
mechanism by which these supplements
would facilitate vasodilation if there's
any impairment of vasodilation occurring
so you look at
some of the studies in younger healthy
individuals and sometimes you don't see
a big effect on vasodilation with these
supplements
in some cases it still improves
performance without
meaningfully affecting vasodilation
through other mechanisms but when you
look in situations where vasodilation
might be impaired
particularly studies with older
individuals who are sedentary these
supplements do a really nice job with
with promoting vasodilation so it's not
just that the atp research is
inconsistent it's that
it looks like it's filling a potential
role here that is already taken care of
by supplements with
much more research supporting them so
for those reasons i'm still very
skeptical of atp supplements and that's
not to disparage any of the individuals
doing research in this area i'm just
really skeptical by nature so i need a
lot of evidence to convince me to open
up my wallet or to convince me to
recommend a supplement i haven't seen it
yet with atp and it's going to take not
just you know one more study showing a
few more bench press reps i need someone
to really show me how it's working and
somehow convinced me to believe that
it's doing these things better than the
supplements that are already available
you know so for me to go with atp over
creatine and a more established
vasodilator i'm just not even close yeah
and just to spell things out more with
the with the creatine comparison one of
the reasons that creatine would be a
preferable supplement to something like
atp even if atp worked is you know let's
say you take some atp it increases
muscle concentration of atp uh one time
you do a set you kind of deplete that
and then you're just back on the the
normal atp re-synthesis treadmill
um whereas with creatine what what
creatine itself does is like it's a
little thing that phos phosphates can
latch onto and then as you deplete atp
during exercise it's a lot quicker to
just kind of take a phosphate from
creatine phosphate and move it over to
an adp to make it an atp again
so that that's a very
quick and efficient little little swap
you can do and then that creatine is
still hanging out in the muscle so
uh you know you finish a set you rest
take some time breathe kind of get back
towards energetic baseline and you can
attach more phosphates to that creatine
that is still in your muscles so
basically with atp it would just be kind
of a one-time use thing whereas higher
creatine concentrations in your muscles
could improve performance you know every
single set over time yeah and that
that's a really good addition because it
contextualizes one of the numbers that i
shared some of the earliest studies on
creatine we're looking at you know in
responders
how much are we actually facilitating
that process that that re-synthesis of
phospho-creatine where the creatine
during rest periods is taking up all of
those phosphates so that it can then
very quickly you know contribute to more
atp production and in responders we're
talking about a 20 to 50 percent
increase in the rate of that
phospho-creatine resynthesis so it is a
noteworthy physiologically meaningful
impact there so with atp supplementation
like i said um it's fascinating i i like
the physiology behind it i think atp if
you like physiology you have to think
atp is interesting because like that
like i said there that's what metabolism
is you're spending most your time
talking about atp
um but yeah i'm just not really there
yet with with atp supplements and i
think there are better options on the
market uh hopefully we'll learn more
about atp in the future but uh for now i
i'd personally say skip it
yeah i mean my uh
my slightly less charitable read of the
literature so actually actually i've got
a question for you okay the 2019 and
2021
studies on atp supplementation uh do you
remember right off the top of your head
if they were industry funded or not
uh i know the 2021
paper was industry funded i don't know
the 2019 paper off the top of my head so
the
like just looking at those results
the first thing that comes to mind for
me
uh is that i know
that
uh one of one of the companies that
sells an atp supplement is pretty active
in in funding research
and
just looking at some of the differences
especially in that 2021 study that were
there
like you know
you you have four sets you only find a
significant difference in one of them uh
the difference like the raw difference
is 1.2 reps and the p value is 0.04
and
you know there's four other
opportunities to find significant
differences the other three sets and
then overall volume
and they didn't find that you know but
they still found one significant
difference paper gets published to me
that
smells a lot like the
the tactic of just like
industry funding studies and then just
kind of picking and choosing
which experiments they want to get
published or not um
you know so it makes me wonder if there
are also a lot of recent null results
that are just kind of sitting around
unpublished somewhere
um
and and to be clear like that's that's
not taking shots at the researchers
themselves like that's a that's a
relatively
common uh approach for for industry
funding to take but
yeah just looking at those results it it
looks like what i would expect
if that strategy were being employed by
industry
yeah i mean you know my thing is i don't
don't
i know you're not doing this but i i
don't try to you know get into the
intentions of what might be going on
behind the scenes or anything like that
um i'm just you know looking at the data
i would assume that there are probably
some acute studies on atp
supplementation that are just sitting in
a
file cabinet that didn't get published
um of the stuff that has been published
one of the reasons i don't i haven't dug
too deeply into the behind-the-scenes
kind of considerations is there's not
even enough out here
in the open to even say like yeah yeah
oh yeah you should definitely be you
know if there were i mean we might know
10 years down the line a meta-analysis
gets published and there's just the
wonkiest looking funnel plot you've ever
seen yeah yeah but yeah there's not even
enough now to
to get an idea of that yeah and also
just not enough to um
not enough to make me so like for
example if there was a study that came
or a supplement that hit the market
and there's like nine studies
even six studies showing considerable
meaningful benefits and it's consistent
there's a mechanism identified uh you
know the effects look the way you would
expect if that mecha mechanism was
working consistently you know if if that
were the case but all the studies were
coming from this one group with this one
funding source who owns the supplement
then you start to say wait a minute
there's a lot of positive data out here
but i'm getting a little uneasy about it
in this case there's not even really
enough positive data to bother digging
into the deep stuff because if someone's
saying like hey i really want to take it
i'm like i don't really know why like
i just don't see enough positive data
out in the open to even bother worrying
about what's going on behind the scenes
you know yeah that's fair uh
next segment yeah all right so i got two
back to back uh one is a sbs article
discussion segment
which is going to be very short um
basically just letting you know there's
a new article on the website by cam gill
looking at rose so you know rose very
popular exercise i don't think we've
ever written about it
about rose on stronger by science before
um
i don't know why just never got around
to it so uh cam hit me up uh and and
just for long time listeners or readers
um if you read
the reverse nordic curl
article on stronger by science from from
a few months ago
same author so yeah it's a it's a really
good article
talking about
how
different planes of movement different
grip widths uh different amounts of
wrist pronation supination how all of
those variables um
might affect which muscles are
predominantly targeted by different row
variations so you know if you're setting
up a training program and you're like
hey i want to i want to train my back
want to get big and i specifically want
to target uh trap development what sort
of rows should i do to grow my traps i
think that article will be
a very helpful resource for
selecting the style of rows that is most
in line with your training goals so
that article is on stronger by
science.com and if you have not read it
yet check it out
absolutely i think uh cameron did a
great job with that i agree good stuff
all right moving on i have a a little
coach's corner segment rare for you you
don't do a lot of coaches corners i
don't i don't uh
i should because it's it's the easiest
stuff to put on
but yeah so i i wanted to
um
i wanted to expand
a little bit on
uh
some of the information you covered in
your big goal setting section both from
your article and uh from a recent
episode of the podcast
and one of the things that i got a fair
number of questions about uh especially
after the article came out
is like people asking like you know i
i understand
like part of the goal hierarchy idea
that you were talking about people
saying like i understand parts of this
stuff like the the underlying process
goals that underpin kind of the
intermediate goals and how you can have
process goals that support
multiple outcome goals and all of that
but there was a bit of confusion about
what actual practical utility a
superordinate goal had so if you
remember
uh if you remember that podcast episode
or that article basically if you're
setting up a goal hierarchy you have
super ordinary goals at the top which
are kind of
uh
like an underlying value like the thing
that your outcome goals are supporting
so
you know let's say you want to
improve your diet you want to start
exercising more regularly
things like that uh your super ordinane
goal might be related to either getting
healthier or maintaining good health
so that's kind of like the overarching
thing that everything else kind of flows
from
so
um yeah i i got some questions about
like just what is the practical utility
of having a super ordnance goal
and i think one of the i think one of
the big things it does for you
um
is i see a lot of people
just
you know
across the internet in the stronger by
science groups and reddit and facebook
and whatnot um who will ask questions
along the lines of like you know hey
like i don't know why but like i've been
pursuing these goals and i i just have
no motivation right now what's going on
and often times you kind of you kind of
interrogate that
and you realize that maybe
they
just got it in their head like hey like
trying to get as strong as possible is a
good thing to do for its own sake so
like i'm i'm just gonna do that and
maybe their training is going well but
like they're just having a hard time
staying motivated to keep going to the
gym
consistently and then he kind of
interrogated a little bit
and you're just like well you know
why do you want to squat 500 pounds like
what what is
underpinning that and oftentimes it's a
question they haven't really even
considered before um
and then you know they think about it a
little bit more and they're like you
know ultimately i decided i wanted to
start lifting in the first place because
like you know got into my 30s used to be
active when i was younger found myself
out of shape and i said ah you know i'll
go to the gym
and then i met up with some power
lifters and they said oh yeah like this
is fun you should try powerlifting
getting strong very cool
so i tried it and then like you know now
i see looking back a couple years later
uh i got into powerlifting and you know
i i fell for the idea that cardio kills
your gains and so you know maybe my
overall activity levels have gone down
even even as i started training i
decided i wanted to be as good as
powerlifting as possible so
uh moved up a couple weight classes when
you know maybe that wouldn't have been
uh the best thing to do for body
composition and general health and then
you look back on it and it's like well
you know ultimately like the super
ordinane goal uh if they would have
framed it that way it's still kind of
the same like you know they're still
somewhere in their late 30s and maybe
they have a young family and they're
like you know i want to be healthy like
that's
that's the main thing i'm interested in
and the initial steps they took were
towards that super ordinance goal and
then at some point
uh you know it kind of got diverted and
they kept setting outcome goals that
were within the same general genre as
when they first went to the gym you know
have some sort of quantifiable thing to
progress on but over time
their
like intermediate outcome goals drifted
pretty far away from what the ultimate
thing they cared about was and the
ultimate thing they wanted to accomplish
and to be clear like i'm not just taking
shots at powerlifting here um you know i
see the same thing happen with like
physique athletes all the time like hey
i went to the gym because i wanted to
get healthy and now like i'm six percent
body fat and my hair's falling out and
my dick doesn't work like that's
you know maybe not uh the most
compatible thing with optimal health so
you know i see
stuff like that happen pretty frequently
where
people start losing
motivation and just never
like maybe never really interrogated in
the first place
why they wanted to accomplish what they
wanted to accomplish
um
or you know maybe they did but they they
hadn't really checked up on it in years
and so i think one of the benefits of
having a clear superordinate goal
is it helps you make sure that the
actual actions you're taking
and the like intermediate quantifiable
goals you're pursuing are still
in service of that thing you you
ultimately care about i think a lot of
times when people do end up losing
motivation it's because
the actions they're taking and the
intermediate quantifiable goals they're
pursuing
um
are are
can become pretty badly misaligned with
the super ordinance goal that they care
about uh that it that if they would have
been more explicit about like what's
driving these outcome goals maybe they
wouldn't have drifted so far away from
it in the first place and i think that
can help
that can help people maintain motivation
like if if your actions and your kind of
underlying drives and motivations are
are better aligned
um
so that's just general advice for people
but it's also general advice for like
trainers and coaches because i
i know that that happens all the time
too like you know let's say a client
comes to you and they say like you know
i just want to i want to move better i
want to have more energy you're a
trainer and so first place your brain
goes it's like well okay let's let's
kind of set some quantifiable goals like
that that we want to pursue when
training this person so they say they
want to move better they want to have
more energy and so you operationalize
that it's like
you know
if we can get this person to be able to
like say do a full squat
and
like do deep lunges that they can that
they can control pretty well relative to
most of the population that that
qualifies as is moving better and
certainly for
a lot of especially middle-aged clients
relative to their starting point that
would be like clear quantifiable
evidence that they are moving better
and they want to get in better shape so
you say like you know let's let's do
some uh
like let's try to get them in better
aerobic shape and since it's kind of a
personal training setup generally your
time with them isn't very long and so
you're not going to make them pay for a
session where it's like ah well you're
going to run on the treadmill for an
hour and i'm going to watch you
see you know you have them do some
interval training in the sessions that
you have with them and so you know early
on
those things that you're doing like just
getting them moving doing some intervals
that's that's very much in line with
helping them get more energy and working
on their mobility and their movement
patterns getting them to be able to
squat and lunge well that's very much in
line with their goal of moving better
but then as
time progresses i think
i think it's pretty easy to kind of lose
sight of what those underlying
motivations were in the first place
so you know they
get to the point where they can do a
deep squat and do it well they get to a
point where they can do lunges with body
weight and control it well so the first
place your brain goes as a trainer is
like well you know
now we're at the point of progressive
overload like they can do the exercises
we wanted them to do so now let's now
let's load them up a little bit
same thing with the interval training
they start getting in better shape and
it's like well you know let's
shorten the rest intervals or push the
intervals a little bit harder or raise
the intensity on them you know whatever
just basic progressive overload
and so you know maybe the first three
months you're working with this client
everything you're doing is very very
much in line with what their goals are
and what they're trying to accomplish
but then you get maybe another six
months down the line and you're training
them as as if they're like a sprint
cyclist uh you know trying to make like
an olympic team or something
and
you know
like they've made a lot of quantifiable
progress but maybe
after you kind of cleared that
three-month mark maybe it's not
necessarily
in line with what they actually wanted
to accomplish and that's something i see
from trainers a lot it's like oh man
like my my clients were making progress
but like they uh
they stopped working with me like their
their motivation seems to be waning but
like they're getting so much stronger or
like they're losing so much weight
what's what's wrong and it's like well
like is is that actually what they
wanted and like sometimes it is and like
clients just suck but
oftentimes i think it is
a matter of just like a
trainer kind of losing sight of what
matters to the client and
you know just over time the the goals
you have set for them and the things
that you're trying to pursue with their
training program maybe drifts away from
the underlying things that actually
matter to the client um so yeah i think
that that's one of the
i think that's that's maybe the biggest
uh practical benefit
of having a clear super ordinane goal um
that you know you don't just mention
once and then never really think about
again but that is actually like pretty
close to top of mind a lot of times
especially as you maybe meet a goal and
you're setting a new one just check back
in like
is the super ordnance still my super
ordinance goal like maybe have my
underlying
drives and motivation shifted over time
if so that's great uh if they haven't
and it's still basically the same
are these new
like quantifiable outcome-focused goals
i'm setting
actually in line with this underlying
thing that does ultimately matter to me
the most and as long as you keep that in
mind i i think it
becomes a lot easier to
maintain motivation with the goals you
set for yourself and to take actions
that allow you to follow through
yeah i'm glad you brought this up
because this is something i talk about
with my clients a lot in coaching
sometimes i'll have clients
fortunately not too frequently because
you know in ideal scenarios clients are
loving their training motivation's high
everything's good but every now and then
i will have this conversation with a
client where
you know they'll kind of mention that
motivation has been really low and you
know it's kind of it's not just like i
had a tough week it's it's been weeks of
low motivation
they'll bring that information to me and
i kind of feel like i get the sense that
they're expecting
some tough love like i'm supposed to say
well you gotta want it bad or something
like that you gotta you gotta tough
through it
and that's never been my approach even
before i dug into this literature about
super ordinary goals and things like
that but it's always seemed really
intuitive to me that
if you are sensing low motivation for a
sustained period of time
you don't really have a motivation
problem you don't really have a
willpower problem you have a
misalignment problem like you mentioned
like the issue there is in my opinion we
have a dog that entered the room the
issue in my opinion is that
what's happening is like you mentioned
there's some drift going on
and our program now is not currently
facilitating the pursuit of a goal that
is still super important to that
individual
and so we need to realign those things
so my first thing is not to do the whole
tough love thing and say hey you got to
pick it up and just do it
i encourage people
take some time to think about you know
what are we doing this for well you know
do we need to reassess what some of our
intermediate goals are do we need to
reassess what our super ordinate goal is
and i think finding that alignment
usually sorts out a lot of the
motivation related issues
and another thing i try to get my
clients away from
when they're feeling that that kind of
like low motivation everything that
we're doing is just kind of grinding and
toiling
there are some short-term scenarios
where you do have to grind out some
tough training blocks
but in many cases i think a lot of times
people
they kind of create this dichotomy of
like instant gratification versus
delayed gratification
and some people
adopt so much focus on delayed
gratification
that they don't enjoy a damn minute
of their training career because they're
always like oh no in 20 years when i'm
way stronger like this will all be worth
it and so what i try to get people to
embrace is the idea of
continuous gratification where of course
we're leading towards some kind of goal
that's important to us but like if we
are not enjoying that process and
feeling great about taking the steps
toward it i i just think there's a huge
missed opportunity to really love what
you're doing there so yeah
it seemed like you you disagree with me
no i i don't disagree with you i think
this is this is a one of my spicier
takes i think the whole concept of
delayed gratification is actually
complete [ __ ]
um so you agree with me more than i
thought yeah yeah no i i don't i don't
think anyone does it
yeah i think that
i think that largely i think everyone is
kind of doing the continuous
gratification thing and i think that a
lot of people
who swear up and down that they're doing
delayed gratification
were just like taught and acculturated
into a particular mindset
that gives them a little dopamine rush
when they do do something that is
typically associated with delayed
gratification yeah such that they're
actually getting their gratification
yeah in the short term like
you know the the classic example that
people always come back to is like you
know saving your money instead of like
spending it every time your paycheck
hits
and like i used to think that with that
i was doing delayed gratification but
dude my my parents just like drilled
that into my head from day one um
because like they didn't come from
uh
a
uh particularly well-off financial
background and so like for for me and my
brother they just drilled into us from a
very early age like spending all of your
money is bad saving money is good and so
like you know when i when i would save i
used to be like oh i'm i'm doing this
good virtuous thing like i'm delaying
gratification and then i thought about
i'm like no it stresses me out to spend
money and i like saving money like
uh
i don't know like i'm i'm doing the
thing that in the short term makes me
feel good because it was like so drilled
into me at an early age that like no it
like if you spend this money that's bad
so
i don't know i i think that that's
um
i think that that's like a mindset that
my parents instilled in me that's that's
helpful in a lot of ways but there
there's no delayed gratification going
on like
spending that money would stress me the
[ __ ] out like it that would not be
short-term gratification
um
so yeah like i don't know i'm sure that
there's a little bit of that that goes
on but i think that a lot of behaviors
that people associate with with delaying
gratification
i think a lot of it is is motivated
by
just like underlying cultural values
that they were taught and kind of like a
sense of duty and whatnot and so that
like when you do those things it makes
you it makes you feel good because you
think like oh i'm doing the good thing
right now see i think everyone's doing
the continuous gratification thing i
think that's a
a complete a completely [ __ ] and
unhelpful false dichotomy yeah well in
either case you know if you are noticing
that you are
really dragging your feet through
training um whether it's because you're
locked into this concept of delayed
gratification or because you just
haven't spent a lot of time pondering
about what your super ordinate goal
truly is
if you find yourself in a position where
your training just feels like a chore
and like a second job that you dread
going to
something is off you should address that
and the recipe to success there is not
more willpower and generating false
motivation because
it probably ain't going to work yeah
definitely not in the long term
all right so moving on to the q and a's
as predicted we are way behind on time
i'm going to go very quickly you know we
could just go back to the old schedule
of
normal episode q a episode if we're if
we're in an hour already we could just
do q a next week yeah i'll do one q a
but then next week we'll do a whole q a
episode cool does that sound good yeah
that works cool
um all right so very quickly i got a
question um i think this was from reddit
the question was does the glycemic index
matter
with macro factor a lot of our users you
know there's in any nutrition space
always questions about carbs versus fat
and then even further into that
conversation you know how do we choose
our carb sources good ones versus bad
ones and so on so one of the things that
comes up a lot is the glycemic index
and i cannot think of
an index or a metric that
has been misused more than this in the
nutrition world
and i'll talk about the
little instance where there might be a
little bit of utility but you know a lot
of times we get this question about the
glycemic index coming from people who
are
you know generally healthy fit
exercising
you know they're consuming mixed meals
with all different sorts of foods in it
and they're like should i should i be
swapping out my carb sources for a lower
glycemic index value carb source so
before we get into the applied stuff the
glycemic index basically what you're
looking at is the area under the curve
they look at the blood glucose response
they you are in a fasted state usually a
12-hour fast they give you that food
alone so not a meal with that food just
that food usually 50 net grams of
carbohydrate worth of that food
you eat that they look at blood glucose
over two hours if you have a huge blood
glucose spike usually that means it was
a really fast digesting carbohydrate
blood glucose goes really high in that
initial period and the glycemic index
value is high and they're all
standardized usually against glucose
which would have a value of 100.
so so it's this quantification of
relative to a standard in many cases
glucose how much does this particular
food spike your blood sugar in isolation
in a fasted state so that seems like a
pretty good idea
initially it came out to help people
with diabetes manage their acute blood
sugar excursions in response to a meal
and especially before they had i think
nowadays a lot of the insulin pumps if
you have a pump are like automated so
they can kind of sense your blood
glucose and then deliver the appropriate
insulin dose but
i'll admit i've never i mean i don't
have diabetes and i've no one in my
family has ever had diabetes but my
understanding is that
there's some degree of calculation going
on before a meal in terms of like okay
based on this meal i might need to have
this much insulin is that fairly
accurate
i don't know but
anyway yeah that seems very plausible to
me that's my understanding of why the
glycemic index came out was basically
hey we need to help people with diabetes
make some informed decisions about not
just their food choices but also you
know how are they going to manage
insulin insulin injections and things
like that so
apologize if you're in clinical
nutrition and i'm just completely
stomping all over that but
the shortcomings of the glycemic index
are numerous especially in the context
of healthy folks who are exercising a
lot so first of all the glycemic index
is measured with a set number of net
carbs like i said usually 50 grams
but that ignores differences in the
energy density of a food right so like
uh watermelon is kind of the classic
example
uh they're like here's 50 net carbs
worth of watermelon which is like so you
just eat seven kilos of watermelon yeah
it's like a tremendous amount of
watermelon and so then it has this high
glycemic index value but it's very
different from saying like here is a
serving of white bread and here is a
serving of watermelon like they're going
to have different net carb values so
that's one of the issues there
it standardizes net carbohydrate which
completely ignores the context of
serving size
another thing is that the glycemic index
like i mentioned usually measured in an
overnight fast
with a single food consumed in isolation
most of the meals we eat other than
breakfast are not in an overnight fasted
state so we're still digesting food from
a previous meal and then the foods that
we eat are usually consumed our carb
sources are consumed along with usually
a protein source a fat source in various
combinations and when you start adding
uh you know
fat and protein and different amounts of
fiber into this mixed meal it
drastically can alter the dynamics of
that glycemic response so all of a
sudden this number that used to be very
relevant is now getting distorted by
interactions with other foods in the
meal
and also i mean the glycemic index value
of a food can change as a fruit ripens
it can change based on the way you
prepare a carb source the way that you
cook it and the degree to which you cook
it and it also just doesn't tell you
about the quality of the food right so
um when you're looking at a carbohydrate
source you might might be thinking about
the vitamin and mineral content you
might be thinking about the fiber
content the energy density the the way
your your gi system tolerates that food
if you're if you're a little bit
sensitive to it the palability of the
food the convenience of the food when it
comes to cooking and storing um if you
get into coaching convenience of food
sources is so important you know like
you can have the best diet plan in the
world put together but if it's like yeah
i don't know how to cook that and i
can't store that and bring it to work
the whole thing is useless
and then of course the cost of a food is
important as well so the glycemic index
doesn't really tell you anything about
those things and in my opinion those are
some of the most important things to
consider when you're evaluating a
carbohydrate source
so
you know they have come out like after
the glycemic index they came out with
the
glycemic load which i'm pretty sure
uh if i'm not mistaken i believe the
whole idea with the glycemic load was to
account for that issue with
standardizing the net carb content i
think glycemic load takes in account the
kind of standard serving size in
addition to like you know the glycemic
response so the glycemic load is a
little bit of a step up from the
glycemic index but it doesn't come
anywhere close to solving all the other
problems associated with the metrics so
when i'm dealing with someone who is not
diabetic who is generally healthy
exercising things like that and they ask
about glycemic index my response is it's
just really not worth worrying about
the
in all my years of coaching
you know i i don't do diabetes
management which is why i know so little
about it i'm actually proud to not know
about it because
i shouldn't yeah if i'm getting in there
like pretending to be the armchair
diabetes counselor like
no that's not what i'm here for yeah um
so like you know i don't do diabetes
management it's a critically important
thing it's just not my expertise and i
leave it to the people who are good at
it so my caveat is if you're working
with a medical practitioner
they you know and they know your medical
situation way better than i do and
they're telling you to be mindful of
these different metrics with your carb
choices of course if you're under
medical supervision working with a
practitioner take their advice but i can
tell you that outside the context of
diabetes where i do my work i have never
once considered or advised someone to
put a lot of thought into the glycemic
index it is a very very limited metric
that has very limited utility
outside of of those clinical
applications
yeah makes sense to me cool all right so
normally with the show we try to keep
the vibes pretty good
to play us out
unfortunately we are bidding farewell to
two individuals very influential people
uh who have had a huge impact on the
world who unfortunately passed away
within the last few weeks here when we
were on break so
uh i'm gonna go first here um
a while ago on the show i had the road
to enlightenment segment where i talked
about how i was doing a lot of reading
about uh buddhism
and you know i started out reading a lot
of stuff by karma yeshi rab gay who is
really fantastic but
after i read through all of his books i
started reading a lot of a lot of books
by tiknot han who
is a
vietnamese zen master
um his impact on the world was
incredible um you know he was
uh
really outspoken about the vietnam war
and in fact martin luther king jr
nominated him for a nobel peace prize
for his uh peace activism surrounding
the vietnam war
i was reading a lot of articles since
his death a little over a week ago
apparently a lot of people who did a lot
of
really important clinical breakthroughs
in terms of
kind of weaving clinical psychology and
mindfulness practice leaned heavily on
some of his earlier books
and credit him for kind of facilitating
the formation of some
clinical psychology techniques that are
still used today as treatments uh so
tiknot han had a huge impact on the
world he is a tremendous writer i've
been reading his books non-stop for the
last like
probably four or five months um
and so um yeah it was really sad to hear
of his passing
a little over a week ago um i really
love his books how to fight how to relax
no mud no lotus those are three of my
favorites but
if you have any interest in
topics that fall under mindfulness
and buddhism or secular buddhism i would
highly encourage you to check out his
books um like i said it was really sad
to get that news that he had passed but
he passed at the age of 95 lived a
remarkable life and had a huge huge
impact
uh and my
my in memoriam is for bud jefferies uh
passed away recently
and um
it that one hit me hard because there
was no
it was very out of the blue like there
was no indication that he was in poor
health um like it was just kind of a a
random thing
uh and he was
he was easily one of my biggest
inspirations uh early in my strength
sports career
uh if you've
we've talked about bud on the podcast
before but if you've never checked out
his stuff you should uh go to his
instagram account uh go i think his old
youtube channel is still up check that
out um
i would say that he was
both strong and
just overall physically capable uh just
in a insane variety of ways like
if uh if you followed bud on instagram
and one of his his posts showed up in
your feed you'd have no idea what he was
about to do um you know he might be
lifting up the back end of a
tractor-trailer truck or he might be
like holding a 200-pound rock overhead
in one hand and like shooting pistol
targets with the other hand like just
just all sorts of stuff um
and i i found that very
inspirational early in my lifting career
um
you know just because like i
didn't want to kind of feel like i was
just locked in to like oh i do one
string sport and that's it
um
and uh he was also just just a very nice
guy so i i've talked about this
on the podcast before as well
but uh like
early in my lifting career i was a very
um
like very excitable and very very
invested teenager and so i used to just
send messages and emails to
the people i looked up to just like
asking them for advice and whatnot
and even back then like when i was very
much a nobody bud was one of the
very very small handful of people who
would actually
like return my emails and
uh send very helpful advice
very very nice guy uh i i've never heard
anyone say a bad thing about him
and uh
so yeah he he was a
he was simultaneously a big
and very underrated part of the strength
community and uh he will definitely be
missed
you know
after hearing that he passed away it
really it caught me by surprise um i
went and
obviously when someone has that big of
an impact there's going to be articles
there's going to be a lot of outpouring
of support on social media posts and
things like that
and i i
did a lot of reading in those articles
and those posts and the thing that
really jumped out to me
was uh
someone had mentioned
uh kind of an anecdote they mentioned
that you know buds uh his feats of
strength were always
a spectacle right like
one of the most recent ones i saw was he
picked up a huge boulder and then shot a
bow and arrow while holding the boulder
and so with those kind of unconventional
feats of strength you're always going to
get people online who come in and make
comments about how
just squat bench and deadlift like that
stuff is silly and of course with way
more
toxicity behind it than that and someone
was sharing an anecdote that they were
that person
there was a video they came on and were
just being mean to him and something
like that
and he responded with so much kindness
and
they were just saying like
one interaction with bud changed the way
that i interact on the internet you know
and that's
that's just such an incredible
legacy to lead or to leave so um yeah
bud really strong guy but really kind
guy i've never interacted with him once
but
to see those kinds of stories of him
changing a person's perspective about
how to treat people is
i mean that's really incredible yeah
all right so i think that does it for
this episode um
as always we appreciate you listening we
will be back once again uh with the new
schedule we'll be back in one week
so take care and we'll talk to you soon